you could be the seventh best player in
the whole world like literally seven
best player but if you're playing with
the other six you're the sucker you are
you are the like the worst player in the
game right so like there's a lot of
players for example like the Dan
bilzerians of the world right he's not a
top level player like you know these
guys you see on TV but he probably makes
more money than they do because he plays
with people that are far below his skill
level so part of the part of the skill
of being a poker player is finding
situations where you're profitable you
know regardless of your skill level
another connection to life uh do you
think Dan balzarian is telling the truth
about having made what is it 50 100
million dollars just a huge amount of
money playing poker considering what I
know about the private games and the
types of players who play in these
private games and the stakes that they
play I absolutely believe you know Dan
has made I don't know how many millions
but I you know whether it's 50 whatever
but it wouldn't surprise me that if you
play in these games within a year or you
know you find the right businessman who
has way too much Bitcoin money you know
and you know in one night you take them
for 20 million I absolutely could see it
I don't see any reason why listen where
he got his money initially you know
that's up to interpretation from his
father or whatever but what but has he
made a bunch of money playing poker
absolutely no question do you feel like
as somebody who loves the game do you
think there's something almost ethically
wrong in playing people much worse than
you
so yeah that's a good question because
you know part of the reason I played
poker and wanted to become professional
was like I want to be make my mother
proud right and I don't think she would
be proud of me taking like Grandma
Betty's like last five dollars you know
and get down the street you know setting
her broke and taking her pension check
so I play at the high stakes against
people who can afford it they know who I
am I'm not a hustler I'm not pretending
I'm bad at poker to squeeze in like I
was thinking about this just yesterday
because I played in a game that
if I played that sort of role where a
lot of guys do Pros they sort of play
down their skill level pretend they're
just one of the guys these guys can make
20 30 million dollars in a year
legitimately like I believe that like if
I did that if I said you know what I'm
gonna go down that path get into these
games in La you know and travel and do
all this kind of stuff I can make 20
million a year but it feels a little
greasy right I don't like to kiss
anyone's ass I don't like to ask it for
anyone for a favor or things like that
so but but yeah like
I I feel listen a rich guy who wants to
sit down with a million bucks and get
drunk and lose it I have no empathy for
that I'm like I don't have any moral
qualms with that so if uh Grandma Betty
is a billionaire uh okay give me send it
send it right you know absolutely why
not